les journalistes de tout compte fait sur
france 2 sont partis enquêter dans les
coulisses de la célèbre marque à la
pomme vous savez le gars là est bien on
a découvert la technique employée par
les vendeurs pour mieux amadouer les
clients est arrivé à vendre leurs
produits 1155 euros minimum l'équivalent
d'un smic voilà donc ce qu'il faut
débourser aujourd'hui pour posséder le
smartphone dernier cri du géant
américain
mais alors comment la marque fait-elle
passer la pilule auprès des
consommateurs d'abord flatter le client
en l'accueillant dans des magasins au
design élégant
ensuite il y à des vendeurs à l'attitude
plutôt cool et à l'argumentaire bien
rodé le client peut parfois être très
critique avec la marque par exemple
c'est trop cher on entend tout le temps
mais comparez le avec d'autres
téléphones regarder la qualité des
matériaux qui sont utilisés
dites-vous campus un iphone c'est dur
quand même plus longtemps qu'il ya un
autre appareil la qualité photo qui est
exceptionnel ce genre d'arguments pour
justifier le prix élevé d'un est faux
alors prix élevés moi je dirais même
prix exorbitants à si vous permettez en
2010 840 millions de téléphones de cette
marque ont été vendus effectivement on
est passés savuth avait commencé en 2007
un téléphone à 399 euros
on en est à un téléphone à 1155 euros la
marge est incroyable la progression est
folle qu'est ce que vous pensez de cette
technique de vente et de cette marque
d'ailleurs qui finalement ne vend plus
vraiment simplement un téléphone elle
vend une idée de communauté de de gens
qui se font partie d'un club fermé
qu'est ce qu'on en pense et qui ont
vendu du rêve pendant des années ils ont
révolutionné un secteur ça c'est vrai
merci aujourd'hui ils sont est donc d'un
rêve qui est complètement terminée
abandon du direct qui nous oblige à
consommer leurs produits si on n'est pas
avec eux on n'est pas de leur bande
c'est incroyable cette venue
pas du tout je suis des années ils ont
arrêté d'innover et depuis des années
pour vous physiquement télé prix pour
faire illusion et nous on doit les
suivre donc non ça ne me fait pas rêver
je mets votre téléphone c'est un
téléphone de cette fameuse lettre tout
pas du tout sa rebelle
c'est comme dans une classe quand on
fait partie des bouffons pas forcément
dit qu'elle avait un avenir à crolles
vous dire je les pousse à une attaque
eric qu'on t'appelle tu appelles elle
veut tout changer
je rappelle tivo que vous êtes en train
de dire tout le mal que vous pensez de
cette de cette marque mais tout à
l'heure en loges si je peux me permettre
notre autre productrice rédac'chef avait
un nouveau téléphone de cette marque
justement vous avez un peu bavé dessus
non pas du tout voici six lettres faille
ou parce que c'est l'achat j'ai dû lui
dire qu'il était jolie elle venait quand
même dingue de maths aux mille euros
dans un téléphone donc je lui ai dit que
je l'aimais tous espèrent qu'elle ne
regarde pas l'émission est dû mais je
m'en fiche de son téléphone non d'accord
travers heures de prendre cette marque
spectacle grave erreur
qu'est ce que vous en pensez vous est ce
que vous dites qu'il faut faire partie
de cette communauté et les gens vendent
à rabais mais depuis le premier jour
madame binhai la solution si on dit
moutons de panurge je vous dit jeudi pas
du tout j'ai qui croire mais souvenez
vous bien
on a dû attendre un an dans le monde
entier en france principalement parce
qu'ils sont sortis en 2007 aux états
unis ses téléphones et le monde entier
ne rêvez plus que d'une chose c'est de
là qu'est l'os et du marketing très
malin bien sûr mais steve jobs pour moi
c'est un maître à penser c'est un
accueil inspirant ils ont révolutionné
le monde de la technologie vous vous
êtes addict
il est décevant mais quand bien même
mehmeti maintenant c'est moi même si la
palme anne rice et c'est ce que les gens
oublient de dire de nous dire ce qui est
très malhonnête c'est que les autres
marques ça se joue à une centaine
d'euros près donc c'est pas genre les
des téléphones qui serait équivalent et
qui coûterait juste 200 balles faut pas
nourrir alors les produits justement ces
produits j'en achète j'ai arrêté d'en
acheter ou je n'en ai jamais acheté et
vous n'en avez jamais acheté la sanction
qui potable
bah écoutez c'est normal vu que vous me
croire mais c'est quasiment un smic
comment voulez vous qu'on puisse
acquérir le dernier mais je les vois les
gens les gens qui paient andy lui va si
mal rires oui à se marier bon j'ai
arrêté d'en acheter pour 19% et j'en
achète souvent à 23 % c'est vrai que
quasiment tous les deux ans il ya un
nouveau téléphone qui sort pourtant
obliger tous les ans à en acheter
régulièrement on reviendra d'ailleurs
sur ce sujet qu'est l'obsolescence
programmée de ces portables de ses
téléphones et vous nous direz ce que
vous en pensez